the water
is one of the strongest characters in
the series but did you know that he's
also an imposter giyu sees himself as an
imposter and a fake and by the end of
this video you will know the full truth
about gyu's tragic backstory his many
powers and abilities and his ultimate
role in the final arcs of the Demon
Slayer story this video will cover extra
material that doesn't even appear in the
manga so even manga readers can learn
brand new info let's get into it giyu
tomioka is the very first hashira that
we meet in the story then in fact we
meet him in chapter 1 of the manga and
episode 1 of the anime while doing his
job and investigating a demon attack
giyu comes across demon nezuko as her
Still Human brother tanjiro is trying to
calm her down and reawaken her Humanity
as a Demon Slayer Gil plans to kill
nezuko but tanjiro begs and pleads with
him not to kill her because he believes
that there must be a way to cure her and
turn her back into a human nezuko still
hadn't consumed any human flesh so there
could still be some way of bringing her
back as a Demon Slayer who has seen
countless horrible acts committed by
demons Kyu thinks that the idea of
trying to turn a demon back into a human
is preposterous once a human becomes a
demon there's no way to turn them back
and there is only one thing that can be
done the demon must be killed so that
they can't go on to hurt innocent people
in the future even though this line of
thinking makes perfect sense to gyu
tanjiro refuses to accept this outcome
and he tries to physically stop guiyu
from herding nezuko now of course
tanjiro at this point in the story isn't
anywhere close to being strong enough to
defeat ahashira like giyu and so gyu
overpowers him but then something
strange happens tanjiro's demon sister
nezuko actually puts herself In Harm's
Way in order to protect her brother from
gyu gyu is stunned to see that a demon
especially a demon who was just recently
transformed decided to actually protect
a Human Instead of devouring them to get
stronger after the draining
transformation process this triggers a
massive inner struggle for guiyu because
what he's seeing happen with his own
eyes seems to go against everything he
knows about demons in the end he decides
to do the unthinkable he spares nezuka's
life for a Demon Slayer to spare a demon
is virtually unheard of and this is even
more true for a hashira when all the
hashira assembled for tanjiro and
nezuko's trial we see exactly how
Disturbed the other hashira are baikyu's
decision most of them want to kill
nezuko immediately and even the thought
of doing anything other than killing a
demon seems crazy to them but guiyu
stands by his decision and he even goes
so far as to promise that he tanjiro and
their Master sakonji urokodaki the
former water hashira will give up their
lives if nezuko ever attacks a human
that is pretty extreme so why would you
decide to put his own life on the line
for some demon girl that he only just
met I mean of course it makes sense from
our perspective as the viewers because
we know that if giu hadn't made this
decision then the whole story of Demon
Slayer would have been totally different
tanjiro was certainly traumatized by
what happened to the rest of his family
but his main driving force throughout
the series is his desire to save nezuko
to find a way to turn her back into a
human if Geo had killed nezuko in
chapter 1 tanjiro would not have had
this driving force and who knows where
he would have ended up in order to
understand why giyo made such a
controversial decision we have to take a
deep dive into his tragic backstory
before we do that if you guys enjoy our
demonside content and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
right now it only takes a second but it
helps me out a lot and if you are part
of the over 50 of people who watch my
videos regularly but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a big favor
and make this video video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
on YouTube is completely free but it
helps me out a lot and it makes a big
difference in chapter 130 of the manga
tanjiro realizes that guiyu seems to be
mad at him for some reason when tajiro
asks why he's mad guiyu says he's
disappointed that tanjiro has been
focusing on hinokami kagura instead of
trying to perfect water breathing in
order to become the water hashira when
tanjira replies that there's already a
water hashira and that is of course Kyu
himself Kyu said that no there is no
legitimate water hashira right now
because he is not the water hashira he
is an imposter initially Geo refuses to
explain what he means by this but after
tanjiro keeps pushing for days and days
guiyu finally reveals that he never
passed his final selection to be fair he
did technically pass but not in the way
that he wanted to giu participated in
the final selection along with a boy
named sabito they were both 13 at the
time and they both lost their families
to Demons they became friends and sabito
impressed guiyu with his courage and
strength however despite the fact that
sabito was the one who killed all the
demons on the mountain everyone but
sabito passed that's because sabito was
the only one who died during that
particular final selection guiyu
believes that his own performance at
that final selection was literally the
opposite of sabito giyu was injured by
the very first demon that he had
encountered and the demon attack left
him in a daze sabito then came to his
rescue and he told another boy to take
care of guiyu while he went off to help
others who were crying out for help by
the time GUI recovered from his injury
the final selection was over he
technically passed because he survived
but sabito the boy who rescued him did
not survive he kept fighting bravely and
saving everyone else and that ended up
costing him his own life in the end as a
result of this tragic event guiyu
doesn't consider himself to be a
legitimate hashira he doesn't believe
that he passed his final selection
fairly he was essentially carried by
another person and then that person paid
for his self-sacrifice with his life
while gyu survived and reaped all the
rewards even though he did none of the
work how could someone who hadn't even
defeated a single demon and had to be
rescued by another person say that he
actually passed his final selection in
short giyu has an imposter syndrome in
relation to the other hashira despite
being extremely strong he doesn't
consider himself to be worthy of
standing side by side with the others he
feels that the other hashira earned
their esteemed positions but he has not
so he sees himself as a fake water
hashira and he wants tanjiro to replace
him as the true water hashira tanjiro
passed his final selection fair and
square and so he deserves the position
more than you but as we know guiyu is
not the only one who met sabito tanjiro
also knows sabito because he met him
during training for his final selection
kind of he kind of met him because he
met the souls of sabito and a girl
called makomo their souls appeared on
Mount sagiri and they helped tanjiro
train for his final selection and
because tanjiro knows both sabito and
guiyu he begins to understand what Kiyu
is going through guiyu feels that he
should have died instead of sabito
because if savito had lived then he he
would have potentially become a much
better Demon Slayer than gyu tanjiro
felt the same way after rengoku died
while protecting him tanjiro felt that
if he had died instead of rengoku then
rengoku could have gone on to do so many
amazing things but instead he gave up
his own life to save tanjiro however
tanjiro then remembers what inosuke said
to him after rengoku's death rengoku
believed in them so they don't have to
worry about anything other than living
up to that taking inspiration from
inosuke tanjiro goes on to say something
similar to giyu he tells them to use the
gift that sabito gave him by Saving his
life Kiyu then remembers an exchange he
had with sabito on Exchange in which
sabito smacked him after giyus said that
he wishes he would have died instead of
his sister as it turns out years ago a
demon attacked guiyu and his sister just
a day before she was supposed to get
married when the demon attacked giyu's
sister willingly sacrificed her own life
in order to protect her brother guillu
didn't think that she should have done
this he believed that she should have
just let him die so that she could go on
and live a happy life and start a family
like she was planning to do but sabito
tells giyu to never disrespect his
sister's death by saying what he just
said he must stay alive because his
sister sacrificed her own life to give
him a future the name of gyu's sister
was tsutako tomioka and her death was so
hard for guiyo to deal with that he had
blocked it out of his mind the truth is
that guiyu lost two people who were
close to him because they chose to
sacrifice themselves to protect him from
a demon this led him to develop a severe
case of survivor's guilt and imposter
syndrome if his life keeps getting saved
by others and if he is powerless to
protect the people closest to him then
how could he call himself a Demon Slayer
let alone a hashira according to the
Demon Slayer fan book since the
existence of demons is not public
knowledge when as a kid guiyu told
people that his sister was killed by a
demon everyone thought he was just
mentally Disturbed and he was sent away
to one of his relatives these relatives
practiced medicine so the Hope was that
they could find a way to help guiyu deal
with his Mental Illness but gee ran away
before arriving at his relative's house
and he almost died alone in the
wilderness luckily he was found by a
hunter who was friends with sakonji and
gyu was then placed in sakonji's care
the giu guide in extra chapters revealed
that after guiyu's encounter with
tanjiro and nezuko some people actually
suspected that GUI was the one who
slaughtered the kamada family because he
had been spotted in the area once again
because most people don't realize that
demons exist they are more likely to
blame demon attacks on wild animals or
on other people and in this case they
tried to blame it on guiyu himself when
we consider gyu's backstory I think that
his past experiences and the issues he
developed as a result of those
experiences ultimately contributed to
his decision to spare nezuku's life the
fact that he feels Unworthy of being a
hashira makes him less sure of himself
as a Demon Slayer and so he is more
open-minded to second guessing himself
every demon slayer's first instinct is
to kill a demon right away and most
hashira wouldn't think twice about it
but because guiyu doesn't think highly
of himself and of his decision-making
abilities he was open-minded enough to
give nezuko a chance and that is what
set the entire demon slayer's story in
motion we all know that giyu has more
than earned his place as one of the
hashira and he is easily one of the
strongest characters in Demon Slayer but
at the same time I can definitely see
where he's coming from there is no way
for him to go back into the past and
redo the moments in his life when others
died to protect him and he couldn't do
anything to help them that is something
that has haunted him for a long time and
no matter how strong he actually becomes
he never forgets his past weakness and
since we're on the topic of how strong
truly is let's talk about all of his
many impressive powers and abilities at
this point I gotta issue a spoiler
warning I will be spoiling everything
related to gyu's powers and what role he
plays in the final arcs of the story so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned we know that as a hashira
Kiyu is one of the strongest demon
Slayers in the world we also know that
this generation of hashira are among the
strongest in history perhaps the
strongest since yorichi's time so being
one of them makes guiyu one of the
strongest demon Slayers in history it
goes without saying that he is
incredibly strong and fast that he has
impeccable reflexes and almost
superhuman endurance and resilience giu
also has unbelievable levels of
willpower and determination which make
him an excellent Demon Slayer he's not
as strong as yorichi himself because
yorichi really was the single strongest
Demon Slayer ever and Gio also isn't as
strong as gyome because we know that
gyome is the strongest hashira of this
current generation nevertheless as the
highly respected and extremely powerful
water hashira giyu is definitely up
there in his fight against upper Moon 3
akasa guiyu manages to impress the demon
with his strength and skill and akasai
is not easily impressed because he only
respects the very strongest of Warriors
as the water hashira giyu uses water
breathing which he learned from the
former water hashira sakonji urokodaki
water breathing has 10 regular forms and
then an 11th form that giyu himself
created and that only guiyu is able to
perform the forms include first form
water surface slash which is a single
concentrated slash the second form is
water wheel which involves the user
jumping in the air and spinning in
mid-air in a circular path in order to
create an attack that resembles a water
wheel the third form is Flowing dance
which involves the user swinging their
sword while mimicking the movements of
flowing water the fourth form is
striking tide which involves using
multiple consecutive slashes while
twisting the user's body in a way that
resembles a powerful water tide the
fifth form is blessed Reign after the
drought which allows the user to kill
the Target in a merciful way so that the
enemy will not suffer this is used on
enemies who are already defeated and
helpless the sixth form is Whirlpool
which involves the user sharply twisting
their upper and lower body and creating
a Whirlpool that will cut through
anything in its path the seventh form is
drop Ripple thrust the fastest technique
of water breathing it amounts to a
single but very quick and accurate stab
the eighth form is waterfall Basin a
vertical cut the ninth form is splashing
water flow turbulent which allows the
user to adapt to shaky footing by
minimizing his Landing time and the size
of the surface needed to land safely the
10th form is constant and flux a
continuous slashing attack that becomes
more powerful with each new rotation
finally the 11th form is gyu's own
custom form called Dead Calm this form
allows the user to essentially go Ultra
Instinct Geo comes his body perfectly
and enters a completely peaceful State
then he blocks deflects and cuts all
attacks with pure Instinct without
needing to even think about them aside
from mastering water breathing and even
improving upon it by creating his own
form gyu obtains multiple other skills
and power-ups throughout the series
which boost the power of his breathing
style this includes Awakening his Demon
Slayer Mark the mark that appears on the
body of a Demon Slayer after certain
specific conditions are met a Demon
Slayer who survives a life-threatening
situation that sees their heart rate
increase to over 200 beats per minute
and their body temperature go over 39
degrees Celsius will be able to manifest
the Demon Slayer Mark the mark almost
always appears years after the user has
been in contact with other demon Slayers
who have the mark the act of Awakening
the mark acts as a major power boost for
every Demon Slayer making them
exponentially stronger and faster The
Awakening of the mark also allows demon
Slayers to attain bright red nichidin
blades turning their blades a bright red
color is essential for demon Slayers
because these blades are able to stop
demon flesh from regenerating obtaining
a red blade is an absolute necessity for
defeating the strongest demons like
muzon and the upper moons it is
important to note that even though the
Demon Slayer Mark enables the Demon
Slayer to attain incredible new
power-ups the power that comes with the
Demon's air mark comes at the cost of
their own lifespan every demon sir who
manifested the mark dies before the age
of 25 and the only known exception is
the strongest Demon Slayer in history
yorichitsugikuni who was born with an
awakened Mark the true extent of gyu's
power is basic showcased in his battle
against upper Moon 3 akazah and in his
contribution to the final fight against
demon daddy muzan in chapter 146 of the
manga akaza confronts tanjiro and guiyu
as they are making their way through the
infinity castle and this leads to one of
the most epic battles in the entire
series akasa remembers tanjiro from his
battle against rengoku and he believes
that tanjiro is still a weakling because
of that akasa is confident that his
punching attacks will be enough to take
down a weakling like tanjiro but tanjiro
immediately impresses both giyu and
akaza with his Mastery of hinokami
kagura giu even acknowledges that
tanjiro's current ability is equal to
ahashiras which really speaks to how far
tanjiro has come since the beginning of
the series a smiling akasa then
acknowledges that kyojiro rengoku was
right when he said that tanjiro is not
weak akaza tells tanjiro that he has his
respect and then the battle continues
with guiyu entering The Fray at this
point akaza is just excited to be
fighting two respectable opponents and
even remarks that it's been 50 years
since he's gotten to fight against a
water hashira akasa notices that giyu
possesses a technique that the water
hashiraki fought before did not and that
is of course giyu's custom 11th form
tanjiro and guiyu engage in some really
good teamwork against akaza and Gio even
manages to cut off akasa's arm but akaza
can regenerate entire limbs in an
instance so even such a major injury has
almost no effect on him akasa is using
his explosive punches and kicks against
gyu's water breathing and tanjiro's Sun
breathing and this fight is an absolute
joy to witness even in the manga and you
better believe that I can't wait to see
this battle animated in the anime so far
the Demon Slayer anime adaptation has
been incredible and it is often even
better than the source material which is
a rare thing in the anime World during
this epic battle again against upper
Moon 3 we get some great action and some
pretty great philosophy as well akasa
and tanjiro both share their completely
different philosophies of life but it's
important to note that all this
philosophy isn't just like talk no Jutsu
because it actually has an impact on the
fight itself the things that tanjiro
says about the importance of helping
other people begins to trigger akasa's
memories of his human life memories that
he had forgotten and suppressed this
fight really does feature so many
awesome elements we get akasa stopping
tanjiro's Blade with his bare hands
tanjiro doing his famous headbutt on
akaza giyu coming in clutch at a crucial
time and more so much more it is during
this battle that giu awakens his Demon
Slayer Mark which gives him a massive
power up and makes him stronger than
ever before and yet even with gyu's
increased strength and speed akasa is
able to adapt and the Fight Continues on
and on and on in in his desperation to
find a way to defeat akaza tanjiro
thinks back to an important lesson that
his father taught him and he finally
unlocks the ability to see into the
transparent world this allows tanjiro to
have better control of his own movements
and also to predict the moves of his
opponent in order to avoid his attacks
thanks to his ability to see the
transparent World Time appears like it's
passing slowly for tanjiro and so he is
able to react much more quickly than
ever before this allows tanjiro to avoid
an attack that akasa thought would
definitely kill him and then while akasa
thinks that tanjiro is already dead
tanjiro is able to eliminate all ill
intentions from his mind unlock the
state of anata and sneak up on akaza
akaza relies on detecting his opponent's
fighting spirit in battle but with a
clear mind and access to the transparent
world tanjiro is able to sneak up on
akaza and take off his head using
hirokamikagura's Setting Sun
transformation and yet akaza is so
determined to keep fighting and get even
stronger that he tries to put his own
head back on guiyu prevents him from
doing it by moving the head away from
the body but even after his head
disintegrates akaza doesn't die akasa's
headless body is still alive and
fighting and he manages to kick a
shocked tanjiro into the wall akaza is
following in muzan's footsteps and
trying to reach the point where he can
overcome losing his head muzan himself
can survive even the act of having his
head cut off by Anita in Blade and akasa
is attempting to evolve his demon form
to do exactly that it looks like akasa's
headless body is about to finish off
both giyu and tanjiro but then suddenly
akasa begins to remember his life as a
human if he chose to keep fighting in
this moment akasa could have killed both
tanjiro and giyu but after he remembers
his human life he realizes that the life
he is living now is not what the people
he loved the most wanted him to do his
life as a demon is the exact opposite of
the life that his loved ones wanted for
him and so akaza decides to stop
fighting and he willingly joins his
loved ones in the afterlife akasa's
decision to die is what ultimately makes
muzan's defeat possible because both
tanjiro and giyu would go on to play an
important role in muzon's Ultimate
defeat now as you might have noticed I
skipped over akasa's backstory in this
video because even though it is really
interesting this video is about guiyu
not akaza however if you want to know
all the tragic details about akasa's
human life then check out my video on
every upper Moon's backstory Link in the
description and in the pinned comment
after defeating akasa both Kiyu and
tanjiro end up fighting muzon along with
a bunch of other demon Slayers including
inosuke zenitsu nezuko mitsuri iguro
sanami and gyome oh and murata there's
also murata in this epic Clash against
five different hashira and a whole bunch
of other powerful demon Slayers muzon
finally Falls the demon Slayers managed
to keep muzan outside until the sun
comes out because the sun is the only
way to kill him giyu suffers multiple
serious injuries during this battle
including the loss of his left arm but
he keeps getting back up and bravely
getting back into the fight along with
the other heroic demon Slayers he is
able to turn his nitrogen blade a bright
red color and he comes in clutch to help
tanjiro against muzon during a key
moment in the battle and not only does
guiyu save tanjiro he also saves other
demon Slayers from tanjiro when muzon
attempts to hijack tanjiro's body in the
end tanjiro regains control of his own
body and muzon perishes forever giyu
survives the battle and we know that he
lives long enough to start a family and
have children these children would go on
to have children of their own and gyu's
descendants will survive all the way up
to the modern era if there was any doubt
about whether Geo was worthy of the
position of hashira at the beginning of
the story that doubt is completely
removed during the akazah and muzan
fights giyu is an incredible hashira a
brave and selfless Warrior a great
mentor to tanjiro and the other lower
ranked demon Sayers and more gyu's
intuition about nezuko and tanjiro from
the very beginning of the story turns
out to be spot on nezuko was indeed a
special demon a demon who did a lot to
help the demon Slayers against her
fellow demons and the first demon who
was able to transform back into a human
and tanjiro was destined to ReDiscover
the Forgotten original breathing style
Sun breathing and put an end to muzon's
1 000 year old reign of terror none of
this would have been possible if guiyu
hadn't decided to put his own life on
the line by sparing the lives of nezuko
and tanjiro the defeat of all the demons
the upper moons and of moves on himself
never would have happened if guiyu had
made a different decision without guiyu
and the faith that he placed in the
kamado siblings there is no Demon Slayer
story so even though guiyu tomioka is a
supporting character and not the main
character in Demon Slayer his overall
impact on the story is absolutely huge
without guiyu's actions and the
extremely difficult decisions he makes
there is no Demon Slayer in some ways we
owe it all to Gil what do you guys think
do you like gyu as a character and who
is your favorite hashira overall if you
were a hashira what kind of hashira
would you be let me know down below if
you want an epic Demon's air video to
watch next and maybe you're interested
in akasa's full back story check out my
video on every demon Moon's backstory
Link in the description and in the
pinned comment if you guys enjoyed this
video and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like right now and
if you're one of the over 50 of people
who watch my videos regularly but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
I'm talking to you right now do me a big
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications